Chimp Haven is a retirement facility
this is their forever home this is where
they come to explore and and live like
chimpanzees in June 2013 the director of
the National Institutes of Health made
an announcement that virtually all of
the chimpanzees would be retired from
research we have close to 200
chimpanzees here now around half of our
colony are veterans of research that was
focused on a cure for hiv/aids as well
as hepatitis C and so as a result of
that those chimpanzees had to be
infected with those viruses good morning
Gina
genetically I'd say we're about 98%
identical to a chimpanzee and as you can
imagine that's why there were ideal
subjects and test studies because they
want to learn more about how they can
benefit humans so I would definitely say
that the human and chimp relationship is
one that is ever-evolving give me their
hand good girl they're a lot like us in
our family dynamics you see siblings
they're interacting they're playing with
one another every relationship is
different it's just like that's with
humans certain individuals you'll have
really close intimate relationships with
some not so much we also have seen some
behavioral changes where chimpanzee
might appear to be overly timid and you
know see a change in that over time we
might see that a chimpanzee is a lot
more interested in exploring the five
and a half acre habitat and this might
have been the first opportunity that
they had to do that
I think it's such a great benefit to
know that this is where they'll live out
the rest of their lives and to know that
despite whatever their path may be we
are at least giving them the opportunity
to live out a time of retirement where
they're with other chimps where they're
able to exhibit these species typical
behaviors if they're just able to be
chimps you know that you know what life
is good